I know what you're thinking you're
thinking I'll sinister ghost movie scary
movies seen it all before that's what I
thought too
sinister so sinister is indeed a scary
movie or horror movie it stars
Ethan Hawke he's an author so he moves
into this new town where this family was
slaughtered the little girl went missing
he's looking into an investigating this
case as inspiration to write his new
novel it already sounds more boring than
it is it did his movie surprised me I
gotta say I was surprised from the first
shot in the movie the first shot in the
entire movie just leaves you going holy
[ __ ] so that's what I'm in for it's some
disturbing ass imagery and it's not the
last time you're gonna see stuff like
that Ethan Hawke finds this batch of
super 8 recordings and they're all these
grisly ass murders that have happened
and I'm telling you the imagery in these
videos you're like the yeah disturbing
yes creepy yes there are moments in
these videos where he comes through and
he stops and he pauses it and you know
those are those little pictures you find
online where it says something like once
you notice it you'll [ __ ] bricks is one
of those pictures you have to look at
for a second then you notice the thing
in this picture that makes it a thing
you're like oh holy crap it took me a
second jumped out at me that happens in
these recordings a couple times it
scares the living [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
you I'm telling you man even thinking
about it and talking about it has the
hair in the back of my neck standing up
I was looking through the scary movies
that I reviewed in the past couple years
I could watch any one of them in the
dark while I'm spraying a pentagram on
the wall while yelling Bloody Mary into
a mirror before I ever watch one of
those super 8 videos and sinister again
I really I'm serious
she's the movie perfect know is it
predictable at times but the best part
is even though it is predictable at
times you know what's gonna happen
you're like the movies gonna scare me
this way this is going to happen and it
scares the [ __ ] out of you anyway I mean
good job movie does I have a couple jump
scares in this movie yes but the thing
that goes along with these jump scares
isn't the fact that something jumps in
front of the screen it's the fact that
the image that you get in front of the
screen that did the jump scare is burned
into your brain and so what you're gonna
think about when you look outside at
night that happened it was just like
maybe I can freak myself out yep just
did there was a corny-ass part in this
movie and sometimes ghost stories and
movies they do this I never really
understood
and why I'm like it's a still image
still images on computers don't move
I suppose if the ghost possessed the
computer the computer would be tweaking
out and doing weird vertical lines but
it didn't it just the image moved it
does make you go for a second but then
you realize you're like oh but wait now
there's been better in this movie and
there will be better to come however was
this movie made to scare the [ __ ] out of
you yes it was doesn't scare the [ __ ]
out of you I don't know I'm not you but
it did scare the [ __ ] out of me I'm a
grown-ass man and I'm filming this video
at 4 a.m. because I just won't be able
to sleep if I'm laying in bed and that's
the best compliment I can give a movie
like this it's exceeded what it's set
out to do this is the best scary movie
I've seen in a while if you're a scary
movie fan you should see it
I'll give sinister the I'd buy it on
blu-ray rating I don't know that I will
buy it on blu-ray but I would to show my
friends so they have the image of this
guy in their head also when you see the
Google image of him he doesn't look that
creepy actually kind of looks like Kane
from WWE but the way they execute it in
the movie just makes him freakier so I'm
not gonna say what is your favorite
scary movie I'm gonna say what is the
scary movie that just made you go I
don't know that I want to see it again
and maybe that is a compliment to the
movie what's the movie that scared the
living [ __ ] out of you whatever it may
be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
you